buonasera a tutti mi chiamo maria
letizia gardoni sono un'imprenditrice
agricola di prima generazione e ho
avviato la mia attività all'età di
vent'anni mentre completava gli studi
universitari in scienze e tecnologie
agrarie attualmente lavoro e collaboro
con l'associazione nazionale un punto
macrobiotico alla quale conferisco
ortaggi e frutta di stagione coltivati
secondo le tecniche della policoltura
amati che ha lo scopo di produrre chino
un cibo sano e salubre che andrà poi
destinato a diete curative senza
intaccare il delicato ecosistema in cui
viviamo questa sera mi prendo l'onere e
l'onore di rappresentare quei tanti
giovani che hanno deciso di investire il
loro futuro nelle campagne italiane che
hanno perciò deciso di non abbandonare
la loro terra d'origine ma che hanno qui
intravisto una possibilità di crescita e
danno intuiti intuito le straordinarie
potenzialità che il settore agricolo è
in grado di offrire a dispetto di tutti
quelli che ritengono che oggi un ritorno
all'agricoltura sia dettato da una crisi
occupazionale ed economica dei nostri
giorni
ci tengo a ricordare a precisare che più
del 50 per cento dei giovani che si
affacciano oggi al mondo rurale
diventano imprenditori agricoli per
passione con la voglia di tramutare i
loro sogni in progetti proprio come ho
fatto io
l'agricoltura italiana e di scenari che
ne fanno da contorno si sono mutati ed
evoluti moltissimo negli ultimi decenni
e questo ha fatto sì che oggi ci sia una
nuova agricoltura che è in grado di
intercettare e soddisfare le nuove
traiettorie nuovi fermenti
le nuove ideologie dei nostri giorni
in questo breve intervento cercherò di
farmi capire come e dove è cambiata
l'agricoltura italiana perché oggi è
così attrattiva nei confronti delle
diverse forme di creatività giovanile e
quali sono i paradigmi che la
definiscono cercherò poi brevemente di
immaginare cosa sarà e cosa avrà da
offrire in un futuro non molto lontano
perché prospettiva prospettiva intesa
ovviamente come potenzialità struttura
come possibilità future quindi
possibilità economica ed occupazionale
ma prospettiva intesa soprattutto nella
accezione prima ovvero come quella
tecnica figurativa che dall'incontro di
tre variabili sul piano cartesiano
genera un'immagine terza tridimensionale
che ha in più il senso della profondità
ecco voluto immaginare che questa terza
immagine tridimensionale fosse appunto
un'impresa agricola che nasce di fatto
dalla collisione dall'incontro di tre
fattori principali che sono la figura
dell'imprenditore agricolo l'ecosistema
inteso soprattutto come contesto socio
culturale economico e politico del paese
ebbene gli strumenti di cui fa uso per
svolgere la sua attività
se pensiamo l'agricoltura degli anni 50
60 pensiamo ad un'agricoltura di
sussistenza con aziende agricole chiuse
in se stesse in quanto realtà di
autoconsumo i mercati erano perlopiù
locali e quindi trasporti e la logistica
non erano ben sviluppati
l'imprenditore agricolo aveva una bassa
scolarizzazione e la sua attività
diciamo era confinata all'interno dei
limiti della propria azienda e quindi
era molto distante dalla realtà urbana
ed alla sua dimensione sociale
nonostante le terre a dire il vero
fossero più accessibili le terre
coltivabili fossero più accessibili e
maggiori i numeri camente rispetto ad
oggi
all'epoca però l'impresa l'agricoltura
italiana
in grado di soddisfare le richieste
alimentari della popolazione
vuoi per una mancata specializzazione
delle culture o per la mancanza di
tecnologie meccaniche che potessero
migliorare i processi produttivi ed è
per questo motivo che alla luce del
secondo dopoguerra al fine di diciamo
soddisfare o comunque consentire
l'autosufficienza alimentare la politica
grata agricola comunitaria ha
rappresentato di fatto il principale
fonte di sussidio per il settore
nonostante l'agricoltore avesse uno
stretto legame con il territorio
dell'epoca e questa è una caratteristica
fondamentale per la qualità e la
valorizzazione delle nostre produzioni
a quell'epoca però non era non aveva una
visione non era in possesso di una
visione di largo raggio di lungo termine
che potesse proiettare l'attività
agricola al di là della sola produzione
di cibo sono troppo avanti eccoci nel
corso come dicevo di degli ultimi anni
l'agricoltura e i paradigmi che la
definiscono sono modifica mente cambiati
si sono evoluti e questo ha fatto sì che
oggi potesse nascere una nuova
imprenditorialità agricola
sicuramente la globalizzazione è stato
il fattore esterno che più di ogni altro
ha determinato la nascita di una nuova
forma di una nuova tipologia di
approccio al settore globale economia
globalizzata significa sì apertura
distensione nei mercati ma significa
anche che bisogna essere in grado e
possedere gli strumenti in grado di
accogliere appunto le opportunità che
questa economia globalizzata può offrire
da qui la evoluzione di creazioni di
beni materiali come ad esempio nuove
logistiche nuovi trasporti ma anche di
beni immateriali come reti di
comunicazioni istituti di istruzione e
formazione professionale
motivo per cui oggi molti giovani
investe nel loro futuro in agricoltura
sia che essi siano abbiano ereditato
l'azienda di famiglia o che siano start
upper risiede nella
capacità di fare oggi di uno c'è 10 100
ettari di terra che siano un'oasi di
multifunzionalità ovvero oggi
l'imprenditore agricolo il giovane che
si affaccia al mondo rurale recuperando
le antiche tradizioni e anche i tessuti
sociali che stanno alla base delle
nostre produzioni ma accostando la
capacità di visione e ha grande spirito
intuitivo e creativo
oggi l'imprenditore agricolo all'interno
della propria azienda passa dalla
produzione di cibo e sua trasformazione
in passa arriva la cessione di servizi
alla società cioè pensiamo solo a gli
agrinido alle fattorie didattiche ai
corsi di ipo e dono terapia fino ad
arrivare alla ricezione turistica
pertanto la volontà
pertanto nel imprenditore agricolo oggi
non risiede solo la volontà di fare
business
poggiando le proprie basi su di sviluppo
su due degli assi strategici del nostro
paese che sono i territori e made in
italy agri agroalimentare
ma oggi il giovane imprenditore agricolo
sente la necessità e realizza la
necessità di svolgere un compito molto
più importante che possa portare
beneficio all'intera comunità ed è per
questo che oggi possiamo definire gli
imprenditori agricoli uomo
l'imprenditore agricolo uomo civico o
addirittura operatore sociale
inoltre in agricoltura oggi posso
portare la testimonianza di come la
creatività trovi occupazione in questo
settore
pensiamo ad esempio a tutti quei giovani
che magari si stanno dedicando all'agri
con mesi oa chi
mette in piedi una linea di
abbigliamento recuperando le fibre
vegetali degli scarti di produzione a
chi alleva dromedari al sud d'italia per
ricavarne latte e formaggi chi collabora
con le pubbliche amministrazioni per la
salvaguardia e il mantenimento e la
gestione dei parchi dei giardini
pubblici o che addirittura controlla e
gestisce la propria stalla tramite
attraverso il suo ipad
questo significa che per quanto il
settore agricolo nasca e continua ad
essere un lavoro artigianale e manuale
le famose braccia rubate all'agricoltura
hanno ancora validità di espressione ma
senza elementi queste braccia oggi non
troverebbero occupazione questi e altri
hanno alle loro spalle un'altra
scolarizzazione una indiscussa
professionalità e la capacità di saper
intercettare e soddisfare i rumori
desideri e le esigenze del pubblico a
cui l'imprenditore agricolo si rivolge
appunto come pubblico intendo clientela
con cui l'imprenditore agricolo oggi
vuole condividere la propria esperienza
professionale in tutti i suoi aspetti da
le caratteristiche tecniche delle
proprie produzioni fino alla loro
valenza emotiva e sentimentale
oggi l'attività di giovane imprenditore
agricolo non rimane confinata
all'interno dell'azienda agricola ma
viene tramandata raccontata esportata
sulle più famose piattaforme digitali
che oggi abbiamo a disposizione i
cosiddetti agricoltori 2.0 fanno oggi
del web marketing e dell ecommerce e la
loro forma di approccio strategica al
mercato mettendo in rete il loro lavoro
quotidiano
la presa di consapevolezza da parte
delle nuove generazioni quindi dei nuovi
imprenditori agricoli che l'attività
agricola ha degli effetti a cascata
sulla società e sull'ambiente in cui
tutti viviamo il tè tutti condividiamo
ha portato i giovani prenditori agricoli
a dar vita alle loro creazioni in un
modo sempre più eco compatibile e
sostenibile possibile vi voglio
ricordare che l'italia infatti è leader
nel settore dell'agricoltura biologica
da qui
l'alto valore aggiunto e l'alta qualità
delle nostre produzioni che sia per
materie prime sia per la storia che
magazine a mense rendere il nostro made
in italy agroalimentare unico al mondo
sono questi alcuni degli aspetti che ci
permettono di dire che nel corso degli
anni
l'agricoltura è passata da una
concezione di sussistenza ad una d
avanguardia e utilizzando un termine
molto caro francesco loccisano che passa
che parlerà dopo di me tutto questo ha
portato a far sì che gli imprenditori
agricoli oggi vengono considerati dei
veri e propri pionieri del cambiamento
cosa mi aspetto dall'agricoltura del
domani beh un'agricoltura che continua
ad evolversi che continua a maturarsi
che sia appunto fondamentale per la
crescita del nostro paese che sia prima
di riferimento punto di ispirazione per
la creazione di un nuovo modello della
nostra società
un'agricoltura sempre più inclusiva
un'agricoltura sempre più a disposizione
della società che porti che ci porti a
parlare di welfare rurale senza destare
incertezze un'agricoltura sempre più che
sia forma date sempre più creativa
innovativa un'agricoltura che possa dare
ai giovani la possibilità di non
abbandonare questo paese ma di investire
qui la crescita e il loro futuro
un'agricoltura che possa dare forma
allora intuiti e che possa loro
testimoniare quanto di buono e di bello
questa italia ad offrire